현재 사업 대지는 선정 역에서 도보로
4분 삼성 중앙역에서 도보로 8분
정도 걸리는 역세권에 위치해 있습니다
사업 대지 면적은 64평 정도
건축물의 연면적은 241 정도이며
건축주 분께서는 현재 글린 생활
시설로의 임대 또는 사업으로 쓰실
것을 염두해 두고
[음악]
계십니다 안녕하세요 bsn 건설
송입니다 오늘은 저희 bsn 건설에서
신축하고 있는 삼성동 현장을 가볼
예정인데요 삼성동 현장은 여기 청남동
한 10분 정도 거리에 있는데 9호선
선정 능력 삼성 중앙역에 위치한
역세권에 있습니다 저희 bsn
건설에서 진행하고 있는 현장을 처음
이렇게 보여 드리기 대해서 되게
떨린데 이런 영상을 자주 보여 드릴
수 있는 시간을 갖도록 노력하겠습니다
한번 이동해
보겠습니다 삼성로 현장에 도착했습니다
저희 삼성 현장을 맡고 계신 저희
이재원 소장님을 필두로 해서 많은
분들이 이렇게 계신데요 이전 선생님이
한 번 한 번씩 소개해드리도록
하겠습니다 저희 현장의 공사 기간은
24년 9월 30일까지가 중공
기한입니다 지하 2층에 지상 7층
규모로 지하 1층 바닥 다을 하기
위한 형틀 작업을 진행하고 있는
중입니다 우리 모든 참재 업체들이
최선의 노력을 해서 최고의 작품을
만들 수 있도록 하겠습니다 다음은
설계 사무실의 김민호 팀장님을
소개드리겠습니다 아네 안녕하세요 저는
삼성동 프로젝트 담당자 bsn 건축사
사무소의 김민우 팀장입니다 어 현재
사업 대지는 선정 능력에서 도보로
4분 삼성중앙역에서 더불어 8분 정도
걸리는 역세권의 위치해 있습니다 사업
대지 면적은 64평 정도 건축물의
연면적은 21평 정도이며 건축주분께서
현재 글린 생활 시설로의 임대 또는
사업으로 쓰실 것 염두해 두고겠습니다
다음은 우리 현장 지하철 구호선 관련
공사 업무를 진행해 주시는 천영
엔진이 러닝의 이사님을
소개드리겠습니다네 안녕하십니까 천양
이지의 권호상 이사라고 합니다 저의
천양 이지는 본 프로젝트에서 철도
보호 지구와 관련된 연관 업무를
갖다가 수행하고 있으며 현재이
신축공사가 철도 시설물에 어떠한
영향을 끼치는지에 대해서 미연에
파악하여서 안전 대책을 갖다가 원활이
간구하는 그런 전반적인 업무를
수행하고 있습니다 다음은 저희 현장에
측근 콘크리트 공사를 맡아서 현장
소장 업무를대 대응해 주시는 철근
콘크리트 업체 소장님을 소개하겠습니다
안녕하십니까 골조 팀을 맡고 있는
공사 대장의 이광철 소장입니다 현장
공사 일정과 품질과 현장 안전을
위해서 최선을 다하도록 하겠습니다
다음은 저희 현장에 전기소방 공사를
맡아서 업을 진행하고 계시는 사장님을
모시겠습니다 예 협진 정기 통신의
양철모
이사입니다 열심히 하자 없는 작업으로
이사람 건설하고 제 이재원 소장님한테
누가 안 되도록 열심히 하겠습니다
다음은 저 소방공사를 진행하고 계시는
사회을 모시겠습니다 안녕하세요 대신
엔지너링 순입니다
앞으로이 삼성동 건축 현장을 위해서
하자 없는 공사를 위해서 열심히도록
하겠습니다 길사원 건설 화이팅 아
지금까지 저희 삼성동 현장 현장
내부를 좀 봤는데요 저희 공정별
회의랑 그리고 안전 관련해서 회의를
좀 진행할 예정인데 사무실로
이동하도록 하겠습니다
[음악]
이용하시죠
님 오시면 간단히 말씀드리겠지만 저희
요즘에 중대대 처법 다 알고 계시죠
그러다 보니까 저희 이제 지금 자체
회사 자체적으로도 위험성 평가 지금
자료는 다 만들어 놨고 이제 현장 각
현장에 배포할 예정인데 작업하시는
분들한테 위험 요소 있으면 꼭 그 뭐
안전 난간 때 철거 있으면 꼭 다시
하고 그리고 위험 인자 있으면은
절대로 저희한테 사전에 보고하고
이렇게 작업하는 걸로 그렇게 좀
진행이 돼야 돼
마찬가지로 뒤 해판 뒤에 보시면은
1월 29 31일이 이제 복공 일단
이장을 반출 할 예정입니다 현재 지상
1층 천정에 천막을 쳐서 모양을 해서
타슬을 하면서 양지의 타설이 될 수
있도록 이렇게 준비를 하고
있습니다
[음악]
내년
9월쯤에 진공이 되면은 다시 한번
여러분들께 완성된 건물을 보여
드리겠습니다 삼성동에서 가장 아름답고
퀄리티 있는 작품으로 보답하겠습니다
감사합니다